starwars the last Jedi just dropped the
chilling but thrilling teaser trailer
that hints at some awesome scenes in the
second installment of the new trilogy
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
and in this video I'm breaking down the
last Jedi teaser and explaining some
intriguing details you might have missed
just be aware I will be discussing
speculation and possible spoilers for
Star Wars the last Jedi so if you want
to avoid those tap in the top right of
the screen for a spoiler free video
tribute to Carrie Fisher at Star Wars
Celebration starting with that first
scene I thought it was interesting that
there's a little parallel to the start
of the force awakens trailer where Finn
popped up in distress while here rey
also appears distressed and I wonder
whether she's just experienced another
forced vision like she did when she
picked up Luke's lightsaber for the
first time in the force awakens and that
dark area in the rocks just behind Rey
feels like it could be the same cave
entrance we see Luke standing in at the
end of the trailer and if you brighten
the image here the walls in the cave
actually looks like part of a tree and
you can also make out what looks like
raised staff by the entrance the idea of
a cave also harks back to the dark side
caves that Luke entered in the Empire
Strikes Back
where he struck down a vision of darth
vader revealing his own face beneath
Vader's mask so getting into the core of
the trailer after the Lucasfilm logo
appears we get some beautiful shots of
axes the location where Rey discovered
Luke at the end of the force awakens we
next get the first of various voices
starting with Luke saying breathe just
breathe and then reach out what do you
see the last words echo back to Yoda who
says reach out sense the force around
you while training Jedi younglings in
episode 2 attack of the clones and the
repeating of the word breathe fits in
with the way that Yoda and obi-wan for
example emphasized the importance of
calmness concentration and mindfulness
when it came to the force and in the
background there are whispers of help me
obi-wan just as a trainer cuts to Leia
examining a star chart then on the shot
of kylo ren's destroyed mask you can
hear darth vader breathing in the
background then the words seduced by the
dark side which obi-wan says when he
appears as a force ghost to Luke in The
Return of the Jedi next we hear Yoda
whisper surrounds us and binds us the
words he said to Luke while training him
the Empire Strikes Back hearing other
voices in the background makes me think
we could well get forced ghosts of
obi-wan Yoda or Anakin Skywalker
appearing in the last Jedi or these
could just be disembodied voices again
like the ones that Rey heard during her
vision in the force awakens now jumping
back to the visuals in the trailer I
really love this shot of ROS hands and
little stones rising up around her which
is reminiscent of Luke levitating
objects when he trained with Yoda on
Dagobah and also reminded me a touch of
Man of Steel as well by the way I think
it's curious that two of these images of
Rey focus on her hand and I wonder
whether the teaser is hinting at
something more here after all the
opening scene to the force awakens was
initially going to be Luke Skywalker's
severed hand with his lightsaber from
the end of the Empire Strikes Back
floating through space next in the
trailer we get this intriguing shot of a
series of books set against some tree
roots on the page of one of the books is
the insignia of the Jedi Order and these
are probably the legendary journal of
the world the worlds were recently
mentioned in row one via chariot my and
Bay's Melba's who are guardians of the
Wills the Wills was George Lucas's
original term for the force when he was
writing the first Star Wars movie and I
think it's very likely we'll see the
term and concept developed in the last
Jedi as for those tree roots
force-sensitive trees appeared outside
the movies in Star Wars Canon like the
Clone Wars animated series and the
shattered Empire comic book series in
the Clone Wars there was a for sensitive
tree in the Jedi Temple on Coruscant and
we know from Han Solo in the force
awakens that Luke likely disappeared to
look for the first Jedi Temple and if he
did indeed find that first Jedi Temple
on act two then it seems quite likely
that these are the fabled journal of the
Wills by the way I also love how the
imagery of Rey's words lines up with the
images on screen when she says light we
get layer
she says darkness and we see kylo ren's
destroyed mask and the word balance
brings us to the Jedi book for the ray
of light illuminating the darkness and
these words also mirror the poem in the
journal of wills which reads first comes
the day then comes the night after the
darkness
shines through the light but after all
that perfect symmetry comes the kicker
with Luke's words it's so much bigger
suggesting that there's much more to it
than this and I'll
come back to that point later the
trainer then breaks into some really
fantastic action scenes first up are
these resistance fighters squaring up to
the new first-order heavy assault
walkers in the distance which although
we can't see them up close here for
getting onto twice the size of a regular
80 80 and have been dubbed gorilla
walkers because of their enormous thick
legs now if you're wondering why those
fighters are giving off a red flare well
the important thing to think about is
that this battle is taking place on the
planet crate which director Rian Johnson
has said is a mineral planet covered in
salt that's home to an abandoned rebel
base if you notice these fighters craft
it seems to be hitting the salt floor
and piercing it which spews out red dust
and notice how all the fighters have a
kind of spike dragging along the salt
floor which is where the red is spearing
from the planet they're on has a red
colored mineral base under the salt so
it looks like they're trying to break up
the ground before they reach the
first-order walkers to create a smoke
screen so the walkers can't see properly
during their attack obviously the scene
calls back to the rebel attack on the
Imperial walkers on the snowy planet
Hoth in the Empire Strikes Back and the
visuals here are absolutely breathtaking
by the way this battle was filmed on
Real Salt Flats in Bolivia it's nice to
see Finn is getting medical attention
here and there's a little of the Arabic
language showing on Finn's pod which
translates as stable indicating that
were likely to see Finn back in action
in the last Jedi the trailer gives us a
very short clips of kylo Ren and
interestingly his scar here looks
different from how raised guard him at
the end of the force awakens for what's
more intriguing is the bright yellow
light behind him because the website
making Star Wars has reported as a scene
in the last Jedi where the forth tree on
act 2 is set on fire we know from the
force awakens that kylo Ren was obsessed
with finding where Luke Skywalker
disappeared to and I wonder whether kylo
found Luke here and has set the tree on
fire and it looks like here we've got
another look at that scene which
appeared in Rey's force vision of Luke
and r2d2 watching what might be his Jedi
training school burned down hopefully
we'll get some more in-depth look at
what happened to Luke and r2d2 and how
his hand ended up like this and the way
the trailer cuts to a scene as phasma
and stormtroopers walking through an
area that's on fire is men
to suggest I think that phasma was there
when Luke's school was destroyed but
actually notice the floor she's walking
on is shiny and if you look up it looks
like this maybe more like the place
where Poe dameron's x-wing is blown up
earlier in the trailer
by the way assuming this isn't a
flashback scene for phasma I guess she
managed to escape the trash compactor on
Starkiller base where Finn and friends
said they dumped her in the force
awakens okay and then the trailer ends
with those chilling words of Luke's it's
time for the Jedi to end now it's a bit
shocking off to eight movies to think
that Star Wars might be trying to do
away with the Jedi but Luke may actually
have a point he's had two of his
relatives turn away from the Jedi to the
dark side of the force so perhaps he
thinks is a better way to wield the
power of the force even combining both
the light and dark sides and what some
fans call the gray Jedi and in fact the
second part of the poem I mentioned
earlier from the Journal of the Worlds
reads the difference they say is only
made right by the resolving of grey
through refined Jedi sight so could the
idea be that a grey force user is going
to replace the old Jedi hence the title
of the movie the last Jedi by the way
the poster for the last Jedi also seems
to be hinting at a possible blurring of
the light side and the dark side has
noticed that raised light favor begins
blue and then changes to red further the
poster so guys what did you think of the
last Jedi teaser trailer and what did
you make of Luke's final words and did
you spot anything else I miss I'd love
to hear your thoughts in the comments
below if you enjoyed this I always
appreciate your likes and shares and
check out some of my other trailer
breakdowns and star wars videos by
tapping or clicking here thanks for
watching and see you next time you
became movie lovers